هل كان لديك أي مخاوف بشأن المجيء إلى
هنا اليوم بشكل جيد تمامًا ، لقد سمعت ما
كان عليك أن تذهب إليه ، كان لدي
مخاوف بشأن مؤسسة
الرئاسة لأنني لست
شخصيًا لدي مخاوف بشأن
السيدة الأولى سأخبرك بها ولكن إذا كان
لديك  رأيت ما كان علينا أن نمر به مع
طائرة الإرساء مع إغلاق جميع النوافذ
بلا حياة ، لذا في أي
مكان كان شديد السواد لم
أر أبدًا العديد من الطائرات من جميع الأنواع
والأشكال والأحجام لم أر أبدًا
أي شيء مثلها
ما الذي سيأتي وأنا أعلم كل
الأشياء التي كانت تحيط بنا
بالسلامة ، لذلك لم يكن لدي أي قلق ،
لكن قلقي الأكبر كان
ربما الأشخاص الذين كانوا معي
بالتأكيد جميعهم باستثناء أعتقد
جون بول  إنه رجل قوي جدًا يمكنه
التعامل مع الوظيفة المناسبة التي يستطيع جون القيام بها